[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je serai mon propre motor désormais
voilà plus de
mentor non c'est pas la
peine des êtres humains
elle n'a plus de mentor après Nicolas
Sarkozi en 2007 et Jean-Louis borlau
depuis fin 2010 quelle leçon RAMAYADE
a-t-elle tiré de ces derniers mois
mouvementé a-t-elle changer sa manière
de faire de la politique cette semaine
nous déshabillons en tout bien tout
honneur la nouvelle responsable du parti
radical qui nous a reçu dans son bureau
place de
Valois Ramade bonjour bonjour alors
votre actualité he comme on dit en ce
moment c'est la sortie de ce livre ce
plaidoyer pour une instruction publique
alors ce livre qui vous a
valu quelques ennuis puisque le
philosophe Jean-Michel mugloni vous a
accusé de plagiaat on va pas refaire la
la polémique qui a un peu occupé les les
médias vous avez-vous expliqué une
erreur de forme en disant que vous aviez
vous étiez trompé dans la dans la
bibliographie en fait j'ai cité trois
fois une personne en pensant que c'était
cette personne qui était concerné en
fait c'était pas celle-là c'était
c'était celui-ci voilà donc la prochaine
fois on le corrigera mais ça veut dire
quand quand on est politique on fait un
livre comme ça comment fait on lit on
compile de la documentation oui c'estd
moi je me fais pas aider donc je fais
tout toute seule du début à la fin et je
n'écris que au mois d'août puisque c'est
la seule période de vacances que j'ai et
et donc je compile tout je commande des
livres sur internet je reçois tout et
voilà je compile tout ça avant l'été et
puis puis ensuite je lis tout ça les
deux premières semaines du mois d'août
et puis je rédige les deux semaines
suivantes ah oui donc c'était écrit
rapidement et ah et rapidement et que
par moi voilà et et c'est parce que
j'adore j'adore écrire c'est mon 4e
livre d'ailleurs ça c'est dire que
depuis 2006 chaque été j'écris un livre
et euh et j'aime ça j'aime j'aime poser
les idées c'est aussi une manière pour
moi de de de sortir
de voilà de l'image un peu réductrice
qu'on se fait de moi et montrer que sur
le fond ben je développe une réflexion
alors on va dire cette fois ça va
peut-être vous nuir parce que vous vous
avez cité vous avez cité qui à la place
de ce philosophe vous avez cité un autre
nom en fait c'est ça Kinsler oui ah
d'accord vous avez confondu les vous
avez en fait parce que cette personne
euh comment dire reproduit dans son blog
les écrits de ce monsieur d'accord mais
sans les citer en fait c'est elle qui
doit si si elle les cite mais moi en en
faisant ma compilation je n'ai retenu
que le bandeau du blog et et pas les les
le nom de l'auteur à la finord côté
politique vous sortez d'une période on
va dire de turbulence he depuis que
depuis le retrait de Jean-Louis borlot
certaines mauvaises langues disent que
vous vous êtes un peu grillé en quittant
l'UMP pour rejoindre le parti radical
alors vous vous la qualifieriez comment
à la période actuelle dans laquelle vous
êtes de profonde liberté liberté de ne
pas être dans un carcan quelconque et
liberté de défendre nos idées comme nous
le
souhaitons depuis que Jean-Luc n'est
plus
candidat moi j'ai repris mon activité
professionnelle j'ai publié un livre et
ça fait travz dans un cabinet de
formation voilà de conseil en ressources
humaines donc griller moi je me suis
engagé au Parti radical avant même de
savoir même d'imaginer que Jean-Luc
borlot pourrait être candidat à
l'élection présidentielle il est devenu
après c'est-à-dire que j'ai adhéré au
Parti radical au mois de décembre ENF
c'était dans l'air pardon c'était dans
l'air quand même c'était pas du tout
dans l'air ah c'était pas du tout tout
dans l'air vous c'était pas du tout dans
l'air absolument pas absolument pas ni
que le Parti radical se sépare de l'UMP
ni qu'il soit candidat jamais jamais
jamais est-ce que vous avez pas
l'impression quand même qu'on on a fait
des comptes 2 ans au droit de l'homme 1
an et demi au sport 6 mois à l'Unesco
vous avez pas l'impression que ça
s'accélère dans votre carrière
dangereusement pourquoi moi je je suis
restée 4 ans au gouvernement
euh je pense que si vous faites la
comptabilité justement vous trouverez
dans la 5 République plus de gens qui
ont fait moins de 4 ans au gouvern
manque plus d'accord ça c'est certain ça
c'est certain euh quand à l'Unesco j'ai
décidé par moi-même de quitter l'UNESCO
à contrecœur d'ailleurs parce que
j'adorais cette cette organisation
c'était l'éducation la culture les
droits de l'homme l'internation enfin
tout ce que j'aime tout ce que je sais
faire donc j'étais très bien mais
simplement tous les jours je me faisais
taper dessus parce que parce que je
soutenais la démarche de Jean-Luc borlau
et à un moment c'est devenu
insupportable parce que je ne pouvais
plus faire mon travail alors on va
revenir justement sur cette sur cette
période et ses commentaires cela dit il
y a quand même quelque chose qui est
assez frappant c'est que même si vous
êtes un peu moins visible que quand vous
étiez au gouvernement du moins l'avez
été un peu moins vous êtes toujours en
tête des classements de de popularité
pas tant que ça il y a François Hollande
qui caracole Martine au BRI machin donc
moi je je en tout cas les spécialistes
de l'opinion relèvent quand même que on
a posé la question à G slimman de
l'institut BVA qui justement explique ça
à partir de quelques moments
particulièrement marquant de votre
parcours on va commencer je vais vous
montrer un petit quelques images avec
votre réaction à ce qui restera comme
une des grosses erreurs de Nicolas
Sarkozi l'annonce de la nomination de
son fils Jean à la tête de l'épad petit
rappel he c'est en 2009 à l'époque tous
les Quades de l'UMP le soutiennent sauf
vous qui prenez vos distances on regarde
l'extrait le commentaire et pour les
téléspectateurs il est aussi question
dans cet extrait de l'affaire polansski
soutenu on s'en souvient par certains
ministres mais pas par vous on regarde
ça ça va me faire des emmerdes dans le
92 je voulais qu'ils oubli quant à cette
affaire Jean Sarkozi ce n'est pas encore
fait je rappelle que ce n'est pas encore
fait que l'élection a lieu le 4 décembre
et que ce sont les élus des hautes
scènes qui portent la responsabilité de
l' lire ou pas et que il vautront en
leur âme et conscience et ce sont eux
qui devront rendre compte devant leurs
électeurs donc c'est c'est à eux de
prendre la responsabilité devant cette
situation vous pensez que rendre compte
devant les électeurs ça veut dire vous
pensez qu'il peut y avoir des
conséquences défavorables vis-à-vis des
électeurs on ne peut pas ignorer
l'émotion que au fond une série de de de
faits d'actualité ou de politique
produis sur sur l'opinion publique euh
l'affaire palonski puis ensuite la
polémique déclenchée sur les écrits de
de Frédéric mitteran euh interpelle
quelque part dans l'opinion publique et
moi je pense qu'il faut que nous soyons
attentifs à cette opinion après cette
interview on a beaucoup dit que ramayad
était la seule à euh attaquer à
critiquer à se démarquer de Nicolas
Sarkozi quand on revoit cet extrait avec
le recul on se dit que finalement elle
est assez prudente non bah tout tout est
vrai tout est vrai d'abord ce qui
explique l'exceptionnelle popularité de
ramaayad dans tous les baromètres
d'opinion même encore aujourd'hui alors
qu'elle est quand même largement retirée
de la vie politique au premier plan en
tout cas elle n'est plus secrétaire
d'État ministre c'est que dans les
ministères de la parole qu'elle a eu et
bien la parole elle l'a prise et elle
est seule
à avoir su prendre la parole avoir ce
courage làà sur l'affaire de l'épad là
on vient le voir on vient de le voir
mais aussi sur la France n'est pas un
paillasson avec Kaddafi et sur un
certain nombre de propos qu'elle a tenu
aussi autour de Ben Ali et à chaque fois
au moment où elle le disait les Français
percevaient qu'elle avait raison et puis
l'histoire lui a plutôt donné raison et
à chaque fois vous avez raison de le
dire les propos qu'elle a tenu ont été
des propos extrêmement mesurés c'estàd
qu'à la fois elle dit clairement que
c'est en gros elle le dit poliment mais
que c'est une énorme erreur en terme
d'opinion publique mais elle le dit avec
courtoisie sans offense pour Jean
Sarkozi vous remarquerez d'abord
d'ailleurs que pendant ces 4 années et
demi elle n'a jamais dit un mot de
travers sur Nicolas Sarkozi on ne peut
pas en dire autant de certains des tout
proches du tout premier cercle de
Nicolas Sarkozi lui-même ramayat dit ce
n'est pas fait elle est très claire
quand elle dit cela elle signifie en
cela qu'un Nicolas Sarkozi qui a dit
très fermement qu'en aucun cas jamais il
ne reviendra en arrê
et bien peut changer d'avis et c'est ce
qui a d'ailleurs énormément vexé le chef
de l'État dans cette dans cette affaire
qu'elle puisse suggérer
qu'éventuellement les choses n'étaient
pas données alors il y a un moment où
certains on considérait qu'elle avait
été là pour le coup vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup trop loin c'était en
2010 d'ailles juste avant de quitter le
le gouvernement lorsqu'elle revenait sur
le discours de Nicolas Sarkozi
concernant l'homme africain prononcé à
Dakar quelques années plutôt Saintor on
lui a fait pendant aant un procès parce
qu'il avait prononcé une phrase
euh qui était que la science pour
l'Occident et l'instinct pour l'Afrique
vous vous souvenez je je me souviens
plus de la formule exacte euh il y avait
eu un malentendu évidemment parce que
c'est pas ça qu'il voulait dire il
voulait pas dire que les Africains
n'avaient pas d'intelligence donc vous
voyez même singor même singor n'a pas
échappé vous défendez SAR jus non je
défends pas Sarkozi j'explique mais
Sarkozi n'est pas un Africain Sarkozi
n'est pas un Africain je vous parle de
de pas besoin d'être africain pour être
choqué par ce genre de phrase moi je
pense que non seulement l'homme africain
est entré dans l'histoire mais il a même
été le premier à y entré parce que je je
connais la culture vous l'avez dit à
Sarkozi ça j'ai pas j'ai pas à dire à
Sarkozi je suis pas son professeur
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je fasse
que je saute sur la tribune et que je
gifle le président de la République
après avoir tenté de le défendre pof
elle change complètement de pied et elle
prononce cette phrase qui est quand même
incroyable quoi non non ah non je va pas
légifler le Président c'est ça fait pas
ça fait PASM on a oublié que on a oublié
qu'un homme politique pouvait s'exprimer
normalement il y a rien de choquant dans
son propos et surtout vous aurez vu que
pendant un long moment elle défend
Nicolas Sarkozi en expliquant que certes
elle n'est pas du tout d'accord avec ce
qu'il vient de dire comme une très large
majorité de Français d'ailleurs mais
quand même temp elle ne veut pas
l'accabler elle en appelle même à sangor
pour justifier les propos que peu de
gens ont justifi hein de Nicolas Sarkozi
sur l'homme africain est-ce qu'il y a
pas un petit calcul du coup quand on
voit ça on se demande s'il y a pas un
petit calcul de ça part quoi je le
défends un peu peut-être même
hypocritement pour dire que j'ai défendu
et puis pof je décoche ma petite flèche
comme ça je m'assure ma notoriété alors
on ne peut pas le savoir je ne suis pas
dans le dans le cerveau des hommes
politiques ce que je sais c'est que si
c'était le cas ce serait assez efficace
puisque là je sais pas si on le verra
dans les extrêms mais il y a une autre
quelque chose de de fréquent aussi chez
ramayad qui une propension à dire
quelque chose et puis ensuite à ehémiser
dans plusieurs émissions
euh et si on lui prête euh des calculs
stratégiques ou tactiques on pourrait se
dire que elle a comme ça pu dire ce
qu'elle avait à dire au français et donc
qu'elle y aura gagné en opinion dans
l'opinion publique et puis qu'ensuite
elle fait un rétropédalage dans certains
médias pour dire non non mais j'ai pas
voulu dire ça ou je l'ai pas dit comme
ça où je l'ai pas dit pour donner des
gages et bien à l'entourage du chef de
l'État et lui dire bah non tu vois
finalement je suis je ne suis pas une si
grande opposante que cela voilà al il
dit quand même que vous êtes super
prudente
dans ce que vous dites parce que là on a
repris deux moments où vous avez été
qualifié de quelqu'un de enfin comme
étant très très imprudent prenant de
grands risques finidement vous êtes très
prudente oui moi j'ai enfin à part sur
le paillasson cadfi
euh toutes les autres histoires de
l'épad jusqu'à l'homme africain j'ai
jamais eu le sentiment d'avoir dit
quelque chose de scandaleux j'ai j'étais
pas venu dans ces émissions pour parler
de ces choses-là euh dans le sur les pad
j'étais venu parler du Tour de France
dont on révélait le tracé cette année-là
donc jeéis vraiment pas venu pour ça
venu parler de dopage et tout ça et de
mon vent tout et puis pour l'homme
africain j'étais vraiment venu pour
parler cétait sur mon parcours et cetera
l'Afrique la France bon et et chaque
fois c'est parti tout seul et et puis on
en a fait tout un ramdam et puis je me
suis rendu compte que bon feignon d'être
organisateur de de tout ça mais je vous
assure que sur l'affaire de l'padf il a
raison je suis j'étais très prudente
j'ai pas eu le sentiment d'avoir dit
quelque chose de scandaleux j'avais pas
du tout suivi cette affaire là de très
près puisque je vous faites le lien
entre l'affaire c'est vrai qu'on se dit
mais pourquoi elle mélange par ris parce
que voilà parce que c'était le point
d'actualité au terme de 2 semaines de
polémique moi j'arrive là comme enfin je
j'étais dans mon esprit beaucoup plus
sévère avec l'affaire palensski où là il
y avait quand même une histoire de viol
d'une petite fille et je ne comprenais
pas pourquoi tous les intellectuels
parisiens montai au créneau pour
défendre
et cette affaire des pad la seule chose
que j'ai dit c'est attention à l'opinion
publique et c'est vrai ce qu'il dit que
il vous en a voulu Nicolas Sarkozi pour
l'effronterie de dire que c'était pas
encore
fait ils m'en on tous beaucoup voulu
cette histoire des pad à ma grande
surprise euh c'était beaucoup plus
violent que pour l'affaire Kaddafi par
exemple parce que dans l'affaire Kaddafi
ouai dans l'affaire Kaddafi j'ai j'ai
j'ai eu j'avais le soutien de certaines
personnes de la majorité même Nadine
moranou vous rendez compte à l'époque
était encore gentil on va voir que on va
comprendre pourquoi vous dites même on
va comprendre pourquoi vous dites même
était gentil et euh et et et donc
l'affaire de l'pades ça a été ça a été
extrêmement violent j'ai dû faire la la
enfin j'ai reçu des coups de fil de tout
le département du des hautes
scènes et là j'ai vraiment eu peur parce
que parce que je me suis dit mais
qu'est-ce que j'ai pu dire de si de si
lourd et de si grave je nétais pas venu
pour critiquer j'était venu juste pour
dire faisons gaffe quand même il dit
finalement vous vous prenez toujours
soin de pas dire du mal de Nicolas
Sarkozi que ce que tous n'ont pas
toujours respecté mais alors pourquoi ça
s'est passé comme ça estce que vous avez
une explication pourquoi suciter
pourquoi est-ce que vous vous avez
sucité tout ça mais je n'ai jamais dit
de mal de Nicolas Sarkozi c'est la
vérité je je ne diraiis jamais de mal de
lui parce que je lui queles que soient
les différences qu'on peut avoir par la
suite sur la question des idées
j'oublierai jamais que c'est lui qui a
fait de moi un membre du gouvernement à
30 ans ça arrive pas tous les jours bon
sang mais oui mais alors pourquoi ils
vous en ont tous voulu sur ce coup là si
vous avez été prudent tout en
improvisant en fait vous avez vous êtes
prudente dans l'improvisation donc vous
vous vous vous vous analysez vous dites
attention je parce que j'ai regardé Jean
Sarkozy comme comme un responsable
politique je l'ai pas vu comme le fils
du président voilà je je je l'ai c'est
quelqu'un que je côtoie dans le
département qui sert des mains qui va
sur les marchés d'ailleurs qui fait tout
ça très bien le département où vous êtes
dans dans les hautes scènes et moi je je
j'ai évoqué le responsable politique
qu'il est quand un moment donné là un
remou aussi fort qui interpelle dans la
République scolaire que nous sommes euh
parce que sur le coup je pensais aux
familles françaises qui ont des enfants
bac plus 5 qui arrivent pas à trouver de
stage donc là bon et euh en fait j'ai
j'ai pas vu qu'il y avait des éléments
de langage on me les a pas donné ah bon
non il y avait des élé tout le monde
avait des éléments de langage on a vu
des extrait pour préparer l'émission
Tout l'UMP monte au créneau pourquoi
vous avez pas les je sais pas je ne sais
pas je dis pas que je les aurais lu
faire oui parce que quand on les regarde
on se dit c'est pas très malin de de
présenter les choses comme ça mais mais
j'ai j'ai j'ai vu Jean Sarkozy comme un
responsable politique et je m'en suis
rendu compte de de l'effet de la chose
quand le soir même mon mon père m'a dit
mais c'est le fils du président tu se
rends compte d'accord donc en fait vous
pensez que ce qui a choqué c'est le côté
un peu laise Majesté finalement voilà
mais je l'ai compris qu'après parce que
je je le voyais comme type normal en
fait et c'est peut-être je manque
peut-être d'expérience je sais
pas vous dites vous avez jamais dit de
mal de Nicolas Sarkozi vous vous lu
serez reconnaissante pour ce ce qu'il a
fait pour vous et cetera bon cela dit on
a quand même l'impression que vous
l'avez déçu je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
déçu j'ai fait de mon mieux il m'a mis
dans des situations impossible au droit
de l'homme il le savait d'ailleurs
lui-même puisqu'il m'a dit après ça tu
sauras tout faire euh situation a était
difficile et j'étais chargé de défendre
les droits de l'homme alors qu'on pas
mal de dictateurs défés à Paris c'est
c'est compliqué après au sport on m'a
mis avec un musé
tutelle qui m'avait accueilli au
gouvernement 2007 d'une manière dont je
m'étais parmise
et même si j'avais essayé deelir tout ça
au fin fond de
moi bon voilà c'était quand même ça et
lui-même après Nicola Sarkozi m'a dit
c'est vrai que je t'ai mis avec des
mines de tutelle qui étaient les plus
dures qu'
soit voilà vous dites j'ai fait ce que
j'ai pu mais vous pensez que vous l'avez
déçu ou pas vous avez des éléments ou
pas je crois que je l'ai pas déçu non
je crois qu'il aurait fait exactement
comme moi simplement et là il est dans
la posture du
président donc il peut pas laisser faire
reste que pour les autres
h certains disent d'ailleurs ça a été
vous l'avez évoqué dans plusieurs
interviews qui vous fait des appels qui
vous a fait quelques appels du pied vous
l'avez d'ailleurs bien
souligné en disant oui il m'a peut-être
fait des appels du
piedis dit non ENF on a cru comprendre
que il m'a félicité pour mon travail à
l'Unesco c'est super contente parce qu'
après des mois pendant des mois la Major
expliqué que je mettais pas les pied à
l'Unesco et puis et puis borlau se
retire et le lendemain en fait j'étais
formidable à UNESCO c'est la politique
je m'habituerai jamais à ça mais ça fait
partie et et donc là vous avez des
contacts avec lui là aujourd'hui
récemment non non mais Président c'est
pas un copain on tap pas à la porte
comme ça on pourrait je sais pas on sait
par exemple on a vu dans la presse qui
cherchait des jeunes femmes pour
incarner de la diversité comme Salim
Massa une fille de ary alors on se dit
il cherche il cherche des des remplac
pour incarner la diversité peut-être
qu'il pourrait essayer de reprendre
contact avec
vous je pas pas pour la diversité je
pense pas parce que pendant pendant 4
ans je me suis avertué à lui démontrer
peut-être qu'à
lui que j'étais pas là pour ça
d'accord en tout cas il cherche
quelqu'un pour remplir cette fonction
visiblement qu'elles y
aillent mais je ça ne donnera rien de
bien rien de bon
pourquoi au début c'est super euh la
droite vous accueille à bras ouvert et
puis vous êtes donc un symbole une icône
on vous met des mots plus grand que vous
sur le dos on vous dit que vous avez pas
le droit d'échouer que vraiment vous
symbolisez la banlieu la France de la
diversité vous comprenez pas tout ça ce
que ça veut dire mais c'est comme ça et
puis euh tant que c'est l'état de grâce
tout va bien puis à partir du moment où
vous commencez à parler à exprimer votre
avis alors je parle même pas de
critiquer là on se rend compte que vous
parlez que vous avez un cerveau et là ça
pose des problèmes ça commence à poser
des problèmes jusqu'à ce que jusqu'à ce
que ça clâche quoi voilà
d'cord nouv
ven si ell veulent rester surtout de la
bouclée d'accord si veulent exister
peut-être pas ce sera le risque des
péril mais la diversité elle est là
quand elle est silencieuse et discrète
vous avez dit tout à l'heure même Nadine
Moran alors certains ont pu se demander
qu'est-ce que ça vou dire ce même NAD
c'est vrai c'est quelqu'un qui a eu la
dent particulièrement dure contre vous
c'est vrai aussi c'est quelqu'un qui est
arrivé comme vous en 2007 un peu dans le
siage de de Nicolas sarzi et on a
l'impression effectivement qu'elle a du
mal à à comprendre ce qui vous motive je
vous fais je vous passe un petit extrait
d'une interview sa
réaction après que vous ayez quitté
l'UNESCO on regarde bien je crois tout
simplement qu'elle n'avait pas d'autres
choix dès lors qu'elle ne respectait pas
le devoir de réserve que se doit toute
ambassadeur et bien elle a décidé de de
démissionner donc c'est c'est son choix
vous lui avez déjà donné ce ce conseil
he il me semble au mois de novembre 2009
soit on cétait soit on s'en va c'est ce
qu'elle fait aujourd'hui finalement
c'est c'est assez logique non là c'était
lorsqu'elle était membre du gouvernement
c'est une autre chose c'est-à-dire que
lorsque vous êtes membre du gouvernement
vous devez respecter la cohésion de
l'équipe gouvernementale si vous n'êtes
pas d'accord vous faites le choix de
partir mais vous ne pouvez pas ne pas
être en désaccord et et rester dans un
dans un gouvernement ça n'est pas
possibleors elle part elle ne va pas
n'importe où éit ambassadeur elle était
elle était ambassadeur donc elle était
comme tous les ambassadeurs euh elle
devait respecter cette obligation de de
réserve elle ne le faisait pas donc elle
a démissionné avant d'être démissionnée
voilà l'UMP elle n'aurait pas obtenu ce
qu'elle ce qu'elle souhaitait elle a
décidé de de partir vers le Parti
radical c'est un engagement que que je
respecte mais en même temps je crois
qu'il ne faut pas qu'elle oublie que si
elle a pu faire ce parcours politique
c'est par parce que Nicolas Sarkozi lui
en a donné tous les moyens alors vous
avez dit vous-même oui c'est vrai d's je
n'oublie pas il m'en a donné tous les
moyens le chic à la
française pas gentil ça ah attendez
excusez-moi mais un acharnement depuis 4
ans et pourquoi je sais pas
demandez-luiuis 4 ans
est au premier r dès qu'il y a un truc
pour décerner ses phrases c'est
impressionnant peutêre parce qu'elle
arrivé comme vous derrière Nicolas sarzi
qu'elle comprend pas votre attitude quoi
elle
dit être plus reconnaissant que ça mais
je suis reconnaissante vis-à-vis de
Nicolas Sarkozi je vois pas le rapport
entre l'UNESCO et Nicolas
Sarkozi et puis elle
invoque des droits un droit de réserve
ouais écoutez je vous rappelle quand
cette fonction ce poste m'a été proposé
je l'ai d'abord décliné j'ai j'ai
remercié énormément parce que c'est un
gros poste et tout mais j'ai d'abord
décliné euh parce que mon mon père étant
diplomate lui-même je savais que quand
on est diplomate il y a a un devoir de
réserve et moi je ne voulais pas arrêter
la politique donc il fallait bien que je
continue à m'exprimer dans la vie
politique française on m'a dit mais mais
non non tu pourras continuer à en faire
regarde RCI c'est Claude Guan regarde
d'abord regarde Roger carucci après le
président lui-même regarde Roger carucci
il est il est ambassadeur de l'OCDE il
fait de la politique il se présente aux
élections d'ailleurs on va le nommer
secrétaire départemental du 92 qui est
poste le plus politique qu' soit et donc
j'ai dit vous êtes sûr euh c'est quand
même bizarre bon mais si si si on est
sûr on est sûr bon et si ça va pas je
pourrais partir oui oui oui voilà alors
évidemment à ce moment-là ni cl guayant
ni moi-même imaginions que Jean-Louis
borlot allait se mettre en mouvement
pour la présidentielle comme je vous
disais tout à l'heure donc on estimait
de de de de chaque du côté de chacun que
bah tout allait se passer normalement
oui ce serait une liberté de parole dans
le cadre de l'UMP de l'UMP évidemment
moi je je je pensais aussi même si ce
sera toujours un peu décalé je pensais
quand même que on allait rester dans ce
cadre là je pensais pas du tout que il y
aurait tout ça après donc j'en ai tiré
les conséquences et alors elle dit quand
même autre chose c'est que si vous avez
quitté l'UMP c'est que vous n'avez pas
obtenu ce que vous vouliez à l'UMP en
clair ce qu'elle dit c'est que si vous
aviez eu ce que vous vouliez aujourd'hui
hein je crois je souhaite à laad Morano
de ne jamais être en
difficulté vraiment parce qu'à ce
moment-là elle se demandera où son les
amis pour la soutenir vous voyez c'est
c'est c'est important en politique euh
voilà mais mais mais c'est vrai que vous
n'aviez pas eu ce que vous vouliez à
l'UMP parce que je crois que vous
vouliez effectivement un poste de de
secrétaire général de l'UMP chargé de la
cohésion sociale euh vous l'avez pas eu
si vous l'aviez eu vous vous défendriez
Nicolas SARC aujourdiag il s'agit pas de
poste il s'agissait d'idées alors
pourquoi ils disent pourquoi ils disent
tous que c'est des postes mais parce
qu'ils ont c'est comme quand ils disent
un ambassadeur on lui a dit qu'elle
avait un devoir de réserve c'est pas la
vérité c'est tout enfin pourquoi
pourquoi voulez vous vous l'prenez en
flagrant délit de dire une chose alors
que la réalité était inverse qu'est-ce
que vous vouzut qu'elle était même pas
au courant peut-être qu'elle était pas
au courant oui peut-être peut-être que
c'est pas qu'on vous a dit que vous
pourriez parler c'est le genre apprendre
les éléments de langage avant de parler
vous savez mais ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que moi je suis je je travaille
ces amis Bertrand secrétaire général de
l'UMP qui m'avait dit travaille sur les
questions de jeunesse ça a commencé
comme ça les questions de jeunesse après
il y a eu Copé avec Bertrand ça se
passait bien avec Copé ça se passait
moins bien et d'ailleurs c'est moi qui
suis allé voir Bertrand parce que on me
reprochait deêre de jouer perso donc je
suis allé voir le collectif pour
apporter ma contribution et là zavier
Bertrand dit bah pourquoi pas la
jeunesse personne veut travailler dessus
et puis c'est compliqué les jeune tout
ça bon donc j'y suis allé comme on
envoie quelqu'un on casse pipe euh pour
le collectif pour éviter ce type de
remarque de de de tel ou tel et puis
effectivement
euh la direction change je propose à
Jean-François Copé de continuer ce que
j'ai commencé avec Xavier pertrand en
élargissant aux questions de d'éducation
et de cohésion sociale il a pas voulu
euh mais je me suis pas contenté de ce
refus c'est qu'au même moment il
préférait lancer le débat sur l'islam
promouvoir les députés
d' voilà d'une certaines droitees en
clair vous vous dites c'est un problème
politique eux ils disent en fait
RAMAYADE elle est capricieuse c'est ce
qu' ce ce ce qui a beaucoup été dit ce
qu'on a pu lire pas pas forcément au
micro mais en et et voilà mais on ne
quitte pas un parti sur un caprice c'est
trop grave c'est trop lourd je sais pas
si on est vraiment capricieux on peut he
on en a vu faire des caprices parfois
mais ple qui font des caprices mais on
dira pas dans la Jupé ou Michel Mar qui
font des caprices voyons mais je pense
que quitter un parti c'est un acte
tellement lourd que cela peut pas
relever du caprice c'est une différence
sur les valeurs c'est pas un simple
désaccord Copé machin non ça ça ne
justifie pas de quitter un parti j'ai vu
qu'il y avait une orientation
stratégique qui avait été entamée avec
le discours de Grenoble qui trouvait là
son paroxisme à ce moment-là et j'en ai
tiré les conséquence
voilà on va arriver che moi à ce momentù
vous avez quitté le parti la manière
dont vous l'avez dit juste avant il y en
a une autre qui a une liberté de parole
en ce moment je voulais vous faire
réagir à ça c'est Rachid Dati François
Fillon c'est le premier ministre de la
France ben moi je suis choquée que au
lieu de s'occuper des Français de leur
difficultés d'aller sur le terrain moi
je suis une fois par semaine en France
au nom de ma famille politique pour
expliquer l'action du gouvernement alors
il est en Corée au Japon c'est un
Premier ministre qui n'a jamais autant
voyagé c'est bien d'aller parler au
coréens au japonais c'est mieux de
s'occuper des Français je crois et
surtout en ce moment donc moi je suis
choqué qu'il soit plus préoccupé par son
avenir personnel alors ce qui l'a
conduit à vouloir se présenter au
législatives à Paris moi je vais vous le
dire parce que maintenant il faut aussi
dire les choses la première c'est qu'il
a dit notamment des ténors de la
majorité c'est qu'il allait être battu
dans la Sarte il suffit de le vérifier
et il a eu effectivement des él éement
pour cela en disant j'allais être battu
dans la Sarte il vaut mieux que j'aille
ailleurs et la deuxième chose c'est
qu'il a dit je veux une circonscription
sans électeur et acquise à la droite
donc c'est facile voilà ce qu'elle
mépris est pour la démocratie et pour
les électeurs voilà et ça continue comme
ça al au début elle faisait à la lre ce
que lui demandait Nicolas Sarkozi
aujourd'hui on voit qu'elle est passée
dans le camp des rebelles quand vous
l'entendez vous dites vous êtes un peu
pareil vous pourriz dire des choses
pareil ou pas du tout je sais pas quoi
dire parce que je me sens pas concernée
par cette discussion oui c'est une BAGAR
entre elle et Françis Fillon VO il ils
se battent tous les deux euh pour un
fromage et je trouve ça désespérant pour
notre notre famille politique en fait
c'est-à-dire ces divisions là euh moi
ell n'aurait elles auraient du sens si
c'était la confrontation de deux projets
mais pas quand c'est des ambitions
personnelles qui sentre Cho en plus deux
personnalités qui sont pas vraiment
miséreuses d'accord bon vous avez évoqué
la décision lourde euh de quitter l'UMP
et c'est vrai qu'à ce moment-là on peut
dire vous avez pris des risques en avril
de suivre Jean-Louis borlot mais alors
ce qui est incroyable c'est qu'on on
vous connait votre Fran parler on vous
attendait la fleur au fusil très
catégorique dans ce que vous dites et là
incroyable vous êtes d'une grande
retenue et là c'est une autre facette de
de ramaillade toujours analysée par Gael
Sliman alors Jean-Louis borlot a annoncé
hier soir qu'il quittait l'UMP est-ce
que vous quittez l'UMP euh moi je je
suis le chemin emprunté par par
Jean-Louis et j'invite d'ailleurs tous
ceux qui sont en quête du même chemin
d'espérance à le faire donc vous allez
quitter l'UMP je fais comme oui je fais
comme lui exactement je suis solidaire
et et déterminé comme lui donc vous
allez quitter l'UMP bah oui de toute
façon on était plus dans les organes
exécutifs ouis c'est alors là c'est un
monument de langue de bois mais
incompréhensible oui parce qu'elle
quitte enfin elle suit Jean-Louis borlau
elle soutient Jean-Louis borlau et puis
elle elle ne quitte pas l'UMP c'estd que
si on écoute
l'interview ah on écoute l'in non non
non il ne elle ne prononce pas le mot je
quitte l'UMP elle ne peut pas le
prononcer elle dit je fais comme
Jean-Louis borlau comme si elle avait
peur d'une éventuelle entourloupe si
vous passez l'expression de Jean-Louis
borlau qui est au dernier moment et que
du coup elle n'aurait pas prononcé le
mot fait pour le coup elle av eu de
l'insttinct voilà pour le coup elle a eu
de l'instinct mais elle s'est trompé
c'était pas c'était pas à ce stade là
que l'entourloup aurait lieu qui est
pour vous le meilleur candidat de droite
pour 2012 Nicolas Sarkozi ou Jean-Louis
borlot ah ça ne se désormais depuis hier
soir ça çaalise pas de cette manière
comment attendez il bienent falloir un
jour que vous allez voter en
201 allez déposer un bultin dans l'UR si
les candidat à borlot VOUS allez choisir
le meilleur candidat de droite à partir
du moment où Jean-Luc borlot a quitté le
MP il n'est pas candidat de l'UMP non
d'accordur candidat de le meilleur
candidat de l'UMP c'est le candidat
naturel de
l'UMP le président Sant je vous parle
RAM du candidat de droite le meilleur
candidat de droite pour 2012 c'est
Jean-Louis borlot ou Nicolas Sarkozy non
mais je je comprends pas votre question
parce que sur la seconde séquence le
meilleur candidat de droite la réponse
doit claquer immédiatement il y a aucun
doute elle suit Jean-Louis borlau le
meilleur candidat de droite c'est
Jean-Louis borlau on comprend même pas
on ne peut même pas comprendre pourquoi
tant de circonvolution et il y a un
troisième paramètre qu'on va retrouver
parfois dans certaines de ces
interventions c'est face à un
journaliste qui et bien insiste un petit
peu on n'est pas loin d'un
mensonge puisque dans les réponses de
ramayad puisquelle dit elle a très bien
compris que Jean-Jacques Bourdin lui
parle du meilleur candidat de droite et
elle elle répond sur l'UMP
elle ne elle fait du George marchetis
vous avez vos questions j'ai vos
réponses j'ai mes réponses mais c'est
incroyable parce qu'elle a quand même
pris des positions très fermes sur plein
de sujets et là finalement on dirait que
c'est anodin ça sangle anodin et enfin
non mais c'est tout à fait anodin non
mais ça peut s'expliquer de deux
manières d'une part de manière assez
durable parce que elle a pris des
positions est fortes au début du du
quinquen de Nicolas Sarkozi qui lui ont
valu plusieurs raels à l'ordre et donc
elle se méfie d'elle-même dans l'absolu
dans ses interventions médiatiques et
puis elle ne veut pas faire un jure à
l'avenir finalement là encore elle a un
vrai flair tout de même puisque depuis
Jean-Louis
borlot a abandonné les siens au milieu
du gay à jeté l'éponge et maintenant euh
le jeu est effectivement ouvert pour
Amad alors il dit quelque chose enfin
vous allez dire ce que vous avez relevé
mais qui qui que nous nous avons trouvé
très intéressant et dit on dirait
queement vous vous méfiez de vous-même
oui parce que enfin à ce moment-là
euh c'est vrai que je dis pas je quitte
l'UMP ouai d'ailleurs là vous le dites
ça y est vous y arrivez là oui parce que
c'est difficile à dire sur le coup euh
c'est pour ça que je disais que c'est un
acte lourd et euh et c'était pas facile
et ben ouais c'était c'était c'était pas
si évident à dire donc j'arrivais pas au
début à le dire c'est vrai et le
meilleur candidat de droite qui est le
meilleur candidat de droite vous y
arriviez pas non
plus parce que je savais pas s'il allait
y aller ah c'était pour ça c'était pas
parce que vous aviez un
doute j'avais il avait pas dit les mots
mais alors ce qui est incroyable
d'ailleurs en préparant l'émission on en
parlait avec un un communicant qui dit
mais enfin normalement quand vous allez
faire une interview comme ça vous savez
que c'est les premières questions qu'on
va vous poser donc normalement euh vous
préparez une réponse ça veut dire que
vous les prépariez pas ces questions
vous les avez pas vous avez pas préparé
l'interview ou comment
vous j'étais rentrée très tard j'avais
un conseil municipal la veille
et que j'ai fini à 4h du matin et
d'ailleurs j'étais pas à l'émission
Jean-Luc borlot dit je vais quitter
l'UMP je vais me présenter machin euh et
pour cause j'étais à mon conseil
municipal et donc j'ai appris pendant ce
conseil municipal qu'il quittait l'UMP
qui se mettait en mouvement qui faisait
la fameuse émission où il annoncait
qu'il quittait l'UMP voil exactement
donc mais je ne le savais pas avant donc
je l'apprends là en S dans des termes
aussi clairs et je termine mon conseil
municipal à 4h du matin et je me
réveille 2h plus tard pour aller devant
Bourdin j'ai j'ai pas encore tiré je
l'avoue toutes les conséquences de ce
qu'il a dit donc je suis dans un entre
deux je lui ai pas parlé j'ai parlé à
personne je suis dans un entre deux ce
que je sais la seule chose dont je suis
sûr c'est que la voix que j'ai choisi du
Parti radical avec les valeurs que ce
parti représente c'est la voie dans
laquelle il faut que je
m'engage et et et ça c'est la c'est la
chose parce que c'est une vérité depuis
des depuis plusieurs mois déjà mais
qu'il soit candidat quand ça j'ai pas la
réponse oui puis c'est ce que vous
disiez finalement vous êtes allé au
Parti radical sans penser finalement
certains ont dit genan-louis borlot a
été trop lentement pour vous il a été
trop viteementou pour moi j'ai dû gérer
quelqueose chose qui était pas prévu
dans mon agenda politique personnel
c'était pas du tout
prévu indépendance parce que pendant des
mois j'ai expliqué que j'étais dans les
deux parties double
adhésion et puis tout d'un coup paf on
sort de l'UMP PAF Jean-Luc borlot et
candidat pour moi c'était cétait
beaucoup en très peu de temps et et sans
préparation cela dit à ce moment-là vous
dites Jean-Louis borlau va plus vite que
vous mais il a un moment vous êtes allé
beaucoup plus vite que Jean-Louis borlau
voilà il va falloir attention il va
falloir discuter au Parti radical euh
pour finir l'émission je voulais vous
montrer quelques autres extraits où là
vous êtes aller très vite il va être
question de Jean-Louis borlau et ça
commence fin septembre lorsque vous
annoncez vous-même que Jean-Louis borlot
sera candidat à la présidentielle c'est
sur Canal Plus et c'est commenté par le
publicitaire Gilles Masson il me l'a dit
qu'il était candidat il vous a dit quoi
vous avez dit à de la housse il me l'a
dit nous ENF moi non mais vous savez
savez attendez vous avez dit il me l'a
dit vous le maintenez il vous l'a dit il
est candidat à moi et à d'autres ah ou
est Candat était candidat d'accord oui
mais on c'est pas nouveau ce que ce que
a pas coup B sera pas têre au premier
tour donc vous allez
participerction decolas pourquoi vous
sifflez la fin du match avant qu'il n'it
commencé oui j'y crois oui j'ai envie
qu'il soit au au second tour de
l'élection présidentiel oui j'ai j'ai
j'ai envie que les Français votent pour
lui et lui fasse confiance parce qu'il
incarne quelque chose qui j'allais dire
antiystème qui ressemble pas aux autres
d'ailleurs il ressemble tellement pas
aux autres que les conservateurs
l'avaient qualifié de zoo pour l'exclure
de de la course de Matillon donc oui les
Français ont ont le droit légitime de
donner sa chance à quelqu'un qui a fait
ses PROE sur le terrain qui a des choses
à dire qui représente une nouvelle offre
politique VO pas mieux que vous comme
porte-parole elle est très offensive
très mordante très incisive donc on a
envie de la suivre elle emporte quand
même l'adhésion il n'empêche que pour un
spécialiste de la communication elle
commet qu qu erreurs elle commet quatre
sorties de route la première c'est
qu'elle annonce il me l'a dit on se
doute bien que c'est à borlau d'annoncer
sa candidature et donc pour le coup
deniso reprend en disant je vous annonce
que borlot est candidat c'est une
première bourde énorme la deuxième
bourde c'est que bah on n'est pas sûr
que borlot lui a dit au final à
postériori parce qu'il se présente pas
la troisième bourde c'est que elle
essaie de se rattraper en disant
attendez attendez attendez c'est pas un
scoop si c'est un sacré scoop donc c'est
une troème sortie de route et la 4ème
sortie de route c'est que elle ressort
un acronyme qui était pas très sympa
pour borlot qui était zoo le
porte-parole n'a pas à dire zoo en
parlant de
son conservateur mais voilà donc c'est
incroyable parce que elle est emportée
par sa Foug qui est très convaincante
mais elle fait quand même en permanence
des sorties de route qui quelque part
décrédibilise un peu sa stature de de
femme politique c'estàd que le gap entre
la popularité et le la crédibilité de
femme d'État est beaucoup trop fort
aujourd'hui donc elle doit vraiment
pouvoir essayer de de combattre ça et
estce que vous appelez donc ces sorties
de route c'est des choses qui
l'empêchent justement de de réduire ce
ce fossé entre les deux c'est ça c'est
c'est absolument les sorties de route en
général la rendre très populaire mais
créer une méfiance de son camp et du
camp adverse qui est vraiment
extrêmement forte alors quelques temps
donc là visiblement effectivement
mauvais pronostic borlot n'est pas
candidat contrairement à ce qu'avait
annoncé ramayad et elle est interrogée
sur le sujet quelques jours plus tard
sur France Inter terre ça y est vous
avez compris aussi la raison majeure de
son jet d'éponge oui oui j'ai compris
les explications qu'il a qu'il a donné
euh des raisons manifestement politique
lié lié à la montée des extrêmes des
populismes lié à à une crise qui
nécessite évidemment une sorte de voilà
de de d'extrême prudence il anticipe
aussi sans doute une recomposition de l'
chiqué politiqu à un moment donné eTTH
et souhaite que le Parti radical et et
tous ceux qui se
reconnaissent dans ces
valeurs soit un pôle de stabilité est-ce
que est-ce que vous avez l'impression
qu'elle cro ce qu'elle dit et que le
message est convainquant mais non mais
elle est pas du tout convaincu ça se
voit qu'elle est pas convaincue par les
explications dans ses hésitations dans
la façon elle dit j'ai entendu les
explications elle a entendu les
explications mais elle a pas entendu
l'homme on comprend qu'elle n'a pas
compris ce choix que vient de faire
borlau quand elle dit c'est c'est des
explications manifestement politique bah
oui oui c'est un homme politique qui se
présente à une élection politique donc
ça ne peut être que manifestement
politique donc non on sent qu'elle n'a
pas compris le retrait de borlau c'est
clair alors juste pour comprendre vous
dites elle est pas à son niveau habituel
ou alors elle est pas bonne dans ce rôle
de porte-parole d'un
parti en désérance quoi parce que parce
que le rôle lui correspond pas ramayad
choisit des hommes des personnes
vraiment je suis convaincu de ça c'estd
qu'elle a pas choisi l'UMP elle a choisi
Sarkozi elle a pas choisi le Parti
radical elle a choisi borlot elle a
choisi de go dans les citations sur son
site et je pense c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui a besoin de mentor vraim
vraiment est-ce que c'est son jeune âge
est-ce que c'est je sais pas sa
formation mais elle a besoin de mentor
et pour le coup c'est quand même très
déstabilisant d'être porte parole d'un
parti que dans le fond elle a pas choisi
elle avait choisi un homme qui ne se
présentera pas bon alors il y a deux
choses on va pas réagir sur le mentor
sur le mentor
après il dit il dit quelque chose il a
une analyse en disant bon vous faites
des sorties de route cette spontanéité
puis moment vous faites des enfin vous
dites des choses qui sont pas comment
dire dans les codes de la communication
alors peut-être que tant mieux
d'ailleurs vous allez peut-être trouver
que c'est très bien il dit ça joue
favorablement sur votre popularité mais
en même temps ça vous empêche d'accéder
à une certaine stature qu'est-ce que
vous en
pensez c'est temp bien et pas bien
ouais sortie de route bon je ne fais que
répercuter ce que jean-lue borlot la
semaine précédente ici
même c'està-dire le dimanche avant son
précédent son retour trait lors de du
basculement du scénat à gauche on était
là et et il confirmait sa candidature
donc dans un contexte où tout le monde
doute où vous explique oh il r pas et
cetera et que vous avez celui en qui
vous avez confiance qui vous dit si dans
les yeux expliquez-moi comment est-ce
que vous vous pouvez lu douter pouvez
pas douter en politique vous avez pas le
droit de douter en politique il faut que
vous soyez sûr de ce que vous faites et
après vous vous trompez bah tant pis
mais donc pour vous c'est pas des
sorties de route c'est c'est c'est la
vérité à ce moment-là et je suis sûr que
jean-lu Borle était sincère à ce
moment-là et que cette affaire là s'est
joué à la fin de la semaine en 48 he ah
ouais et vous avez compris sur quoi ça
s'est joué parce qu'il dit là quel une
semaine après vous avez pas l'air
convaincu par ces explications vous êtes
toujours c'est vrai c'est vrai que quand
j'entends ce qu'il dit à la
télévision la montée du Front national
ça fait quand même 8 mois qu'on nous
explique
que blot doit pas être candidat à
causeavé du Fran national et nous on
contreargumentait la crise bon ça fait
des mois qu' la crise cont enfin voilà
euh donc j'étais je peux pas dire autre
chose que que ce qu'il a dit parce que
je ne suis pas dans la dans la vérité de
dans son fort intérieur mais je pense
que la raison est à rechercher dans son
fort intérieur ah d'accord vous pense
pour ça après un peu maintenant vous
avez du recul vous avez j'imagine
enquêter entre guillemets sur le sujet
vous pensez que c'est quel d'extrêmement
intime et personnel oui je je crois même
pas que ce soit des pressions ou que
parce qu'on a beaucoup dit peut-être que
l'Élisée l'a menacé je pensis un moment
un truc particulièrement grave ou qui
viendrait même pas de l'Élysée forcément
d'ailleurs c'est c'est pas la question
c'est la peur qu'on découvre des choses
sur lui ben non c'est pas ça c'est pas
les raisons politiques donc moi j'en ai
conclu
que mais au bout de longtemps enfin au
bout de de ou de semaines à peu près que
c'était psychologique c'était personnel
c'està dire il avait il ne voulait pas y
aller dans les condition
présente c'est quelqu'un qui a un esprit
très
Grenel il faut qu'il rassemble autour de
lui avant de s'engager ouis peut-être
qu'il avait pas assez rassemblé on va
vous direà et ben c'était ça
c'est-à-dire que je crois que la raison
psychologique et même politique profonde
c'est celle-là c'est il ne se sentait
pas dans un contexte suffisamment de
confiance malgré la bonne volonté de ses
amis je parle des appareils pour se dire
je peux y aller en étant confortable
d'accord donc c'est psychologique dans
ce sens là quoi il sentait pas assez
assez je c'est ça la raison et alors
pour finir l'émission On va terminer
juste quand même sur vous parce qu'on av
donc Jean-Louis borlot et et vous et il
y a ce qui dit en fait il y a votre
popularitéf ce que dit le communicquant
il y a votre popularité et puis il y a
accéder à un certain statut et on voit
on a l'impression que il y a un petit
peu enfin d'après ce qui décrit les les
les deux qui pevent être un peu
antagoniste pour vous la priorité c'est
quoi c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est cette
popularité cette liberté de ton ou c'est
un moment d'accéder bon quand même vous
êtes en politique depuis quelques années
maintenant vous pouvez pas être
éternellement la jeune rebelle c'est
d'accéder à ce statut
euh je suis pas fausse enfin je ne peux
pas jouer le
personnage statutaire qu'on me demande
de
jouer mais ça viendra je pense je je
c'est pour ça que j'écris j'en suis à
mon 4e livre vous en connaissez vous de
ma génération don j'ai écris qure livres
c'est pour ça que que j'ai un club de
réflexion s'appelle al enfant d'accord
c'est un autre moyen d'acquérir cette
entre guillemets maturité si si je
m'échine dans mon territoire à me battre
en éant en devenant conseer municipal
puis conseill régional dans des
territoires qui sont qui sont pas acquis
à la droite et au centre euh et que je
sois comme ça dans la bataille au
quotidien pour reconquérir sa participe
aussi ou en vous présentant d'ailleurs
sans doute législative contre un
candidat UMP sortant dans les hautes
scènes ouais donc en prenant ouais on
verra c'est c'est juste ma
circonscription et il a dit dernière
chose il dit bon vous avez adhéré à
l'UMP pour Nicolas Sarkozi après il y a
eu Jean-Louis borlot vous avez besoin de
menteur alors est-ce que c'est est-ce
que c'est le cas et puis est-ce qu'ils
vous ont déçu du coup ces deux menteurs
est-ce que vous allez vous en chercher
TR beaucoup en
fait bon ben dans ce cas-là vaut mieux
ne pas en avoir non mais vous en es
votre réflexion ment de votre réflexion
ben je serai mon propre mentor désormais
voilà plus de mentor non c'est pas la
peine ce ne sont que des êtres humains
ouis et ça c'est quelque chose que vous
avez après la après le renoncement de
Jean-Louis borlau non mais même avant
peut-être pas au début peut-être pas au
tout début mais même avant euh aussi
aussi fort soit-il aussi puissant
soit-il ce ne sont que des hommes on
Maram son propre mentor merci beaucoup
pour cette interview
merci c'est pour ça que je pe pas
soutenir Mo
déjà deè si elle a pu faire ce parcours
politique c'est parce que Nicolas
Sarkozi lui en a donné tous les moyens
elle est quand même largement retiré de
la vie politique au premier plan en tout
cas au premier
Planier